I want to talk about something that's
sort of a blend of bad economics crony
capitalism and nepotism and it relates
to the recent scale-up of tariffs by the
United States on other countries and
also by China and Europe on the United
States and to quickly catch you up Trump
is putting tariffs on foreign steel and
aluminum turns out that actually China
doesn't export that much of those
materials to the US so Trump has also
added hundreds of products from China to
the list of tariff products and China is
going to retaliate exactly as predicted
they're putting tariffs on about a
hundred american-made goods and
materials which represent about half of
Chinese imports to the United States and
as it happens there is a specific
industry that is going to be exempt from
or spared by Trump's tariffs on China
and that is the clothing industry and it
just so happens that Donald Trump's
daughter Ivanka Trump has a clothing
line and a shoe line and I believe a
handbag line which is mostly
manufactured in China which is going to
be unaffected by the tariffs great news
I guess and of course the official
reason for the exclusion of clothing is
that well listen if we put the tariff on
clothing that would have high consumer
impact and the idea of the tariffs is to
keep consumer impact low
so both clothing and toys are on the
list of exempt items from China and of
course it's very very hard to believe
because the Trump family has these
startling conflicts of interest Ivanka
Trump is going to earn between one and
one and a half million dollars this year
from the businesses of the Trump family
she's simultaneously working as an
unofficial consultant or advisor to the
president she goes around the world at
the g20 South Korea I believe in a
number of other places representing the
United States again not even legally
able to have a job in the White House
because of anti-nepotism laws and she
has it both ways she's using her
unofficial position to not have to
respond to legal actions like for
example Ivanka was recently sued by a
fashion label which alleged that she
stole their shoe designs her lawyer said
listen she's kind of a high-level public
official here in the United States you
can't depose her and at the same time
she doesn't officially have a position
because she can't because of
anti-nepotism
tizen laws and now it just happens that
she is also going to be spared or her
company is going to be spared from these
tariffs on Trump this is where I would
really like to see more bipartisanship
because most people really have a strong
gut reaction to the sort of swamp
filling or draining that has been
promised and most people have these
anti-corruption tendencies and some of
them will get beyond it and just say I'm
gonna give the guy a pass because he's
making America great again or whatever
but I would love to just see more
consensus from the American public
specifically on this swamp issue because
it's just been swamped filling and crony
capitalism and we just don't see
understandably people are busy they have
jobs they're protesting a lot of
different things this one we should be
able to get consensus on I think we're
getting closer you do think so I really
do yeah because I guess I mean it's
anecdotal because with my show I get
feedback from people from all over the
country yep but I am getting a lot of
feedback from people that were like this
is not what I thought was going to
happen you know so it's like people
voted for and I felt the same way I
don't know if you know this but I voted
for George W Bush in 2000 I did not know
that yeah I was 18 years old my parents
were Republicans what we do yep so I had
that process of being like oh my god
yeah and I think that is what's
happening to a lot of people that were
on Team Republican they liked what he
said I mean during the debates there
were moments where I liked what he said
interesting and so now people are seeing
the policies and they're seeing the
constant lies some of them so obvious
that even the most loving Trump
supporter can't deny them at this point
and so I think we're actually seeing
that I think that there was an awakening
for people like me during the George W
Bush administration I just started
paying attention earlier but I'm seeing
it in my own life I'm seeing it my own
audience you know people who were just
loyal Republicans are going oh wait
there are things going on here that I
was never aware my concern is that there
are there is a higher degree of
cognitive dissonance here because there
had to be a lot of suspension of concern
with Trump because not really a lifelong
Republican said a lot of the wrong quote
wrong things as a Republican but people
said listen we really don't like Hillary
and after all he did win the Republican
primary we're going to vote for him and
I do feel at the level of cognitive
is higher this time where we might see
people for their own sake not willing to
have that as a former guest of mine said
a come-to-jesus moment a term I
completely don't ever use but it's sort
of as interesting here I think that
because of the cognitive dissonance they
they will prevent they their minds will
not allow themselves to sort of come to
terms the way you came to terms with the
george w bush thing and that's
absolutely gonna happen with some people
but what i'm more encouraged by is those
people in the middle that we're paying
attention not at all and that didn't
vote at all yeah and just weren't
involved at all this is waking them up
and again i think that they are between
the people that are already sold that
trump is a bad idea
yep and the people that were just kind
of ambivalent to the whole thing yeah I
think that's about 75% of us it's enough
to win elections that's the really
important thing about all it matters it
and that's what I've been saying which
is there's a midterm coming up there's a
real opportunity here and that's what
the focus should be on today's episode
of the program is made possible in part
by
indogene oh the custom menswear line I
recently went to indogene oh I worked
with Chris at their Boston showroom and
I got a custom suit and it's just so
much better than a generic off-the-rack
suit and it really doesn't have to cost
an arm and a leg I went in Chris took
some measurements we looked at different
fabric options button options lapel
styles and jacket lining all sorts of
really personalizable options and then
two or three weeks later a brand new
custom made to measure suit showed up
that has immediately become my favorite
suit now you might be saying David I
don't live near one of Indo chinos
showrooms what do I do what you do is
you go to Indo Chino comm and you can
actually use their online app to take
your measurements put them into their
system design your suit and you can
still get a really great custom-made
suit and this week my viewers and
listeners can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for 359 at Indo Chino comm when you
enter the code Pakman at checkout that
is over 50% off regular price for a
premium made to
suit I actually need a light tan suit
I'm going to one of these Cape Cod
weddings where if you don't show up with
a nice light tan suit you're basically
seen as a savage and I am no Savage so
that's gonna be my next suit from Indo
Chino and shipping is free
that's Indo Chino kaam promo code Pakman
get any premium suit for 359 plus free
shipping great deal for a perfectly
custom tailored suit